you gotta be proud of this I am I'm so
proud of this I actually I mean it's
funny I I feel because I love the source
material so much I love my cast so much
I love the way we got to make it and
when I say to people it's really good
like it's mine I feel like it came
through us and then we were able to make
it I don't feel like I'm bragging
so I'll just say I think it's working
with Saoirse again
does it help always to work with
somebody who you know so well I don't
know cuz I've really only had this
experience with grant insertion I
totally agreed helped a lot to have a
rhythm movie said there's a look a long
history of people who always just loved
working together right like tons of
actors who always loved working together
have you guys talked or you like we know
we should do next
like this and it's the craziest idea is
something that you guys both want to try
together
I don't we have another that conscious
conversation but it's good to save the
universe and good to say out loud like
the gratitude for what even has been
because if it was game over now this
would already be really in large part
rooms solely because thanks to her yeah
I guess Sony in a 24 whatever yeah it's
it Street it's an exception and you look
at Lauren and yeah but I've been
watching Greta a girl she's right here
I'm watching bredda and Laura and you
know she's Laura's I've seen no Bombyx
movie this year too and yeah
Laura's like from that kind of royalties
not even right word no any is you know
and it's inspiring yeah yeah an actor's
actor i watching her like career over
time with like David Lynch is so
fascinating you know everyone since she
was 18 till now and and he's such an
artist and she's such an artist and how
they came up together and and I yeah I
love that idea of like community of
actors and writers and directors and
pushing each other so just like sort of
fans fans love to see actors work
together i I mean I love watching them
work together also Timothy and Saoirse
what's so fun about them is they're so
wildly talented and so committed to
their craft and there they come at it in
such a different way that it creates
something it has just a particular
energy I mean I'm not a musician but
it's like when certain musicians
together and you're like oh my god this
creates a third thing and I feel like
with Timothy and Saoirse there's like a
third thing because it's it's it's this
combining of the way she acts and the
way he acts it creates something when
you say action and the voice you hear is
Meryl Streep what does that do are you
prepared for that can you be prepared I
don't say action no I mean also action
always made me feel like an art no I say
when you're ready um it's amazing you -
it's a she's somebody's like oh how do
you direct Meryl Streep and the truth is
with great actors deep love being
directed because they can do anything
you ask the show so um I mean the truth
is I don't really need to
why wouldn't I let you know you want it
but it's still mine and it's still my
credit yeah but it she's she's six
obviously she's extraordinary yeah you
know um your hair was a big topic with
the ladies downstairs with cotton like
this when your hair is so perfectly just
not perfect but you're outside and
there's win you never care it's never I
had a discussion with York our DP and I
love well I mean he's he's French and a
lot of I feel like particularly French
new-wave movies have are able to do
period pieces that feel utterly modern
one reason is the feeling of editing the
feeling of the movement of the camera
but also they don't care about
continuity at all and it makes it feel
alive somehow and Scorsese has the same
thing in all of his movies he doesn't
care about continuity sometimes even
people are holding coffee cups and then
they cut back and they cut back it's
gone and you're like but it gives it
some quality of madness would I like so
I never cared if his hair was one way or
another I like cutting between things
that don't perfectly match because to me
it makes it feels constructed which is
why I don't like shooting with two
cameras
I can avoid it because I don't like a
perfectly matched cut I think it makes
me uncomfortable when you look at some
of the people I live with Lauren and now
Elizabeth where the worlds that people
can now live in with movies you can do
these you can then go do star wars you
can do Marvel you can do dune you can do
all this stuff that's sort of larger
world where the fans are what they are
how interested are both of you in
dipping into those world he's dipped
into what do fans are what they or you
or Star Wars or a Marvel movie you could
spend the rest of your life and
conference for the rest of your life it
is a life-changing thing to dip into to
dip into that get to that world how
comfortable are you guys with with with
that sort of now is that it's like is
that what a woman included or there's
just like that you can measure something
like little women but then you can also
go and like that yeah that's the freedom
to do that yes I feel like um I feel
like by way of social media and
fracturing of media and fracturing of a
consumer base and niche fandoms there's
a pessimism about like that I have
entertainment or whatever like high
aspirational you know our media going
forward and yes the amazing thing about
what you just alluded to from our side
even from a career perspective or
whatever just the amount of stuff that's
out there is you're less pigeon-holed in
some way I feel and it's really cool
like I took about this people good
whatever sometimes but I feel like at my
age and you know 10 years ago when he's
gone for Saoirse to maybe like you it
would have been way more pigeon-holed or
something there's more I don't know
opportunity in some way I don't know
yeah yeah and now it's like so to do
something like doing and then just to
make an exception in that that's also
because I the same way I would do
anything Greta we do literally and I'll
be a wall or door chair but the same
thing would you need felt like well I
love the book after I read that if I
loved it but that's an excellent film in
herself yeah that's I mean that's what's
cool about like Saoirse and Timothy and
this commitment to I mean then evil move
is a great filmmaker and
he had a passion for this this project
and I mean I don't know I mean I don't
know I feel like the things I respond to
it's not about whether it's I respond to
whether or not is it is is is there the
the heart of it that you feel is
personal and interesting Craddock and
and the truth is that can be on
something that's a huge movie or it can
be something that's on a small movie
personal and an idiosyncratic filmmaking
exists at every level and that's always
what I'm interested in one last quick
question is a fantastic scene in the
movie where Joe sells her first story
for 20 bucks yeah do you remember your
reaction when you booked your first gig
oh absolutely yeah it was I I don't know
went to the right place in my psyche or
so I was like PAH I was really like
there was a booth job that you did think
you liked next stop the top that's like
that was more just delusion but but the
other thing knows it was just exciting
because yeah and maybe less so now cuz
Instagram and stuff people can just like
put themselves out there but you know
it's like a relic in some way no king
but to the idea that like okay I went
into a room and I went to another one I
went to another room and then I did the
thing and I shot in from a big fancy
machine and now it's like yeah if you
see that's a crazy yeah you know yeah
first for me it was them I don't know
why this is it's not it's not selling I
think I'm getting a job but like when I
got my into the Screen Actors Guild and
I got the writers get like getting the
cards of your your your Union man now
like there's something about that that I
was just like I have a trade hmm it felt
kind of like meaningful and also because
you know unions meant something for my
man oh yeah let me say that that uh that
that point about like my personal want
your syncretic filmmaking that's it's a
good thing last thing you see about
little women that even though this has
been a book that has been adapted before
and it's something that's been with our
cultural
time this is so personal to Greta in
ways that I couldn't even you know
imagine I'm sure the details in there
Easter eggs I'm not even aware of but
it's this is not I've learned in reading
projects or just being aware of things
that are there were people like direct
from the heart it bodes well you know as
opposed to like some intellectual
exercise and that wasn't a question I'm
just saying that so and I appreciate all
of that thank you